you squeeze tout sable là où j'en
tirerai sursis forez pour faire une
seconde vidéo dessus d'un père vous a
terriblement plus et ça m'a fait plaisir
je me suis dit on va pouvoir approfondir
un peu la chose donc la séance tarte je
retire le star et vous allez voir qu'on
ait eu
voilà voilà voilà les députés de
sauvageons celle où la balle à bas
carbone elle est là et elle est belle on
peut le dire elle commence à être un peu
construit j'ai rasé à peu près la moitié
des terres de cette forêt et à la
semaine encore des troncs et lads le
jour ce haut au jour est dense où es tu
bref à temps au [ __ ] [ __ ] d'oiseaux
qui se prend pour un sauvageon ça va les
conneries j'ai expliqué problème il ya
j'ai construit un piège
de l'autre côté de la pente j'espère
qu'on va entendre un cri plutôt fort est
plutôt douloureux de la part d'une de
ces trois personnes qui vole mes fesses
ou devrais je dire ma peau des fesses
bref c'est parti on finit la cabane à
tanger mourir de faim ou jasper db yes
ce me semble un peu de temps pour
chasser
oui parce qu'on peut manger db alors il
y en a qui sont empoisonnés et quoi il
est moins je fais une sorte de mais bon
là on peut voir qu'il n'a pas fait une
sorte de don qu'elle ne soit pas
empoisonner logiquement petit animal qui
veut à manger compass forêt à la db
voilà comment on a pu le voir il a fait
une sorte de talent il y avait tous les
animaux de la map à côté de ma cabane et
là il y en a plus aucun oui j'avais un
truc là non pas du tout alors c'est que
vous avez tous envie qu'on aille sur
cette île n'a pas autant que moi
malheureusement on peut pas dans cette
première alpha petit animal mais ces
sauvageons jussieu les ont chassé tout
ce qui bouge et il me reste plus rien
quoi vite [ __ ] non tu étais ma seule
chance de survie mais il y avait des
animaux partout ici avait des lapins des
lézards des aides des lions des
dinosaures vivaient tous là y'a plus
rien oh [ __ ] deux d'un coup allume le
feu allait mais le dessus c'est en fait
c'est cuit madea chances de survie
bon we are 2e 2e à deux hommes il faut
toujours des stocks bien là je n'ai pas
tué ton frère ne t'en fais pas il et
j'ai juste pris dans la maison voilà pas
de problème c'était un mensonge désolé
oui mais il a aussi regardé il ya un
gros cul d'animal naquit ramper par
terre
or depuis à david et au japon comme pas
mal de trucs son jeu notamment qu'on
pouvait casser les valises que yahvé au
pied de l'avion avec notre h et bref
vous m'avez dit des tas d'autres trucs
je sais pas ce qui est vrai ou faux dont
je préfère ne rien dire
en tout cas moi j'ai fait ma cabane ici
voilà je trouvais que c'était un petit
peu il y avait un petit paysage assez
mignon à côté on peut le dire bon après
il nous en faut neuf pour faire une
porte parce que sinon ils peuvent
rentrer à la maison et ça j'avoue que
c'est un peu con le moment le plus
intense de toute ma vie
j'aimerais bien avoir une porte avant
que ces barbares poilus aux fesses nues
nous attaquent
c'est l'heure de construire la porte wow
louise d'or ah mais non c'est un mur
avec une c'est une blague
ces paraphes ce n'est pas séparable j'ai
une autre idée j'ai une autre idée on
colle bien ben voilà c'est bon c'est bon
mec je sens que ce que j'ai fait ça paye
tout marche le deuxième moment le plus
intense toute ma vie elle est ou la
porte
elle est où la porte est juste un [ __ ]
trou dans le mur et là aussi un [ __ ]
de trous mais vous regardez il ya une
porte là sur le dessin voit bien il ya
eu deux portes voilà une porte en bois
tranquillement elle pense que tout à
fait bonjour monsieur ces facteurs a et
pourquoi sur le résultat final importe
c'est ça la porte c'est tout par terre
mais non non on attend déjà des
acheteurs au nonce la maison si on fait
le mur défensif on en mer là pour cacher
ce trou ont pas passé d'accord ok on va
faire on va faire un piège de ouf
tac nickel y'a plus qu'à couper du bois
en masse qu'est ce qu'on fait on est en
fait le piège en premier n'en savait le
piège car tout a bien fonctionné dans
les deux précédentes un ouais y'a un mec
oh [ __ ] et attribue un mais je suis
même pas dans ma maison car à quoi sert
une maison si ya pas de porc [ __ ] sans
déconner est-ce que chez vous la porte
d'entrée c'est un trou banon comme ça on
fait cuire notre lapin moment en place à
les cui cui cui cui manquerait plus
qu'ils arrivent qui me vole mon lapin et
kim but ça va quand même reportage jeune
garçon sho que tu t'es cru là mais pas
chez les minimes ans et en fait je pense
qu'ils vont revenir jusqu'à ce que je
les buts je ne suis pas et ne serai
probablement jamais prêt à débuter oui
hôpital sont là-bas attendait il faut
pas faire ce piège est ok il faut trois
buts à un en fait on fait on fait on
fait c'est beaucoup
voici au milieu je suppose mais c'est
une [ __ ] de blague payer un [ __ ] de
l'apa qui vient de déclencher mon piège
mais plus tard et je peux même pas me
ramasser en plus de ça [ __ ] mais
rendez moi mes rondes à rebours c'est
moi mes roues d'un homme et je me suis
fait arnaquer mais un truc de dingue
hu et des étoiles de mer en pleurs hamas
et non ça va what gpat est mon gars que
tu sais que ça mais ça explique tout
bien sûr que le but et voit un mec
sentait de 10 mars n'a pas du tout la
chute tu as entendu dans cette vidéo je
m'excuse vraiment y adp et les verts
repousse [ __ ] c'est génial au km en il
manque plein plein de brindilles qu'on
obtient sur s'est petit à petit ces
petites merdes d'arbres
darbo y what you're gone est heureux
dans une maison qu'apparaître porte me
tuer oui un lézard et ça ça donne de
l'armure alors si je pouvais avoir tous
mes points d'armure au max je serai
l'homme le plus heureux de la planète
terre c'est leur d'activer le piège
tatataaa ok alors j'espère juste que oui
ou non il faut qu un [ __ ] de lapin
passe ici c'était dans l'autre sens oh
là là non ne paniquez pas attendez un
peu avant paniqués on pourra partir à
l'exploration après si vous voulez quand
j'aurai 70 mille points d'armure a
envoyé on sait pas trop où sont passés
les mecs qui voulait me tuer juste avant
mais ma foi on ne va pas s'en plaindre
ok ok ok où vous pourrez jamais vous
n'aurez jamais j'ai construit une
forteresse sur votre île band matin à
tous les enfants réagi est ce que je
leur fait peur les intimide là on peut
le dire je vais vous montrer un truc on
peut combiner ça et ça pour faire une
magnifique h 100 fois moins stylé que la
hache qu'on a trouvé dans l'avion on
peut les comparer ici tout est d'accord
est-ce que partout à hazard on mange et
on les attaque ça vous tente
normand dans les valises on peut trouver
non une lampe torche qui éclaire à peu
près un million de fois mieux que ce
briquet parce que le bris qu'elle s'auto
quitté clair c'est au [ __ ] je t'ai vu
mme au début je t'ai vu mon garage geder
mur [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] maman maman maman maman en effet
affecté piège ils se prendront les pieds
dans mon moi ta forme assez lent piège
passé dans le piège par milliers mange
des vêtements gdb au passage - genève et
ses parents s'inquiètent pas ya juste
une bande de gros psychopathique
poursuivre tu as le temps de manger des
baies regarder mais il ya une lampe
torche 6,6 et scotty de l'obtention de
fonds le mec quoi est fait que c'est un
[ __ ] de ricola ouais mais là je
m'enferme c'est des mecs là bas sur
l'île
non c'est bon c'est arbustes mais c'est
flippant airbus mais qui dit un mec tu
attaques dit d'accord donc toi d'accord
ok y compris la loi la déportation ne
l'est pas pas de soucis qu'est ce tu
veux question voila voila jamais dit
quoi faut gérer il faut gérer il faut
gérer et il a peur du coup il fait chaud
mais je suis pas sûr de moi et m'a mis
quelques coups de hache dans le nom
latin funk il faut courir oui il faut
courir qui a dit qu'il fallait gérer on
n'a pas les femmes non mais non mais
regardez ça y est ils ont adopté ma
maison elle n'est pas à vendre
[ __ ] mais ces mecs contre une agence
immobilière c'est sûr je fais pas la
seule chose que je veux c'est comme
modèle j'en buvais
et j'ai fait cette blague dans 70 autres
vidéo je vois rien ça se trouve je vais
droit dans leur grotte boîte
le jeu a craché non il n'y a aucun mot
de la langue française qu'ils puissent
exprimer ce que je ressens actuelle
l'avion atterrit manière aléatoire à
chaque fois que vous recommencez une
partie des îles atterri juste à côté de
la [ __ ] de mer il ya plein de gens
d'entre vous qui m'ont dit que c'est un
très très bon spot pour se poser voyez
on peut casser des valises en mettant un
coup de hache
ah non [ __ ] c'est ça hein quand on
sait on ce crash a coûté d'un comprendre
mec quoi mais sérieusement après 20
minutes d'intense y survit au quai
georges auric habitués la situation j'ai
construit une espèce de cabanes super
nul à chier je le suis je sais alors
vous inquiétez pas vous verserez pas en
disant ça il ya toujours pas de porte
malheureusement oui ça c'est un fait
juste ici j'ai construit un totem avec
les membres d'un mec qui était déjà mort
sur la plage je sais pas trop comment
mais il était mort et je pensais que ça
les fait rire pas du tout inquiétant
construction là bas ce piège s'activer
sur rien du tout est là actuellement je
suis en train de mourir de froid
donc je reste bien à côté du feu et il
ya les mecs qui sont juste là bas voilà
bien je partage le feu avec toi regardez
il m'attaque pas c'est incroyable c'est
un spectacle très rare dans la nature
c'est aussi rare qu'une éclipse là ce
qui se passe bon elle des fois elle a un
petit peu des montées d'adrénaline hop
j'ai besoin de toi un truc génial ce
qu'on appelle une lampe torche au propos
éloignez vous éloignez vous aurez [ __ ]
c'est balmont et chauffer les fesses
éloignez-vous ils ont peur du feu je
crois il s'éloigne des cas du feu ah non
je me suis faut que j'aille dans la
flotte je me suis brûlé il profite au
moment où faiblesse cette boulette elle
s'est brûlé à y mettant du temps je
crois qu'il n'est même pas la lumière de
la lampe torche et la lumière rouge
comme ça ça veut dire que les piles sont
un peu morte alors beach ben oui tu peux
créer ça change rien je l'aurais maison
et toi tu es dehors tout du pied du un
[ __ ] il a osé le faire chez moi alors
lu mon gars y meurt meurt il faut lui
mettre combien de coups watts et voilà
je suis mort voilà un coup comme ça et
ils sont forts
il a suffi d'un est terminé pour moi oui
même les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette
deuxième vidéo sofres et j'espère que ça
vous aura plu moi en tout cas j'ai
découvert plein de choses depuis la
preuve de condat fait sur le jeu là je
pense que je vais attendre qu'il y ait
la deuxième version de la feuille qui
sortent pour qu'un peu plus de contenu
qu'on découvre
plus de choses ça vous a plu n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo ça fera vraiment
plaisir et puis je vous dis à très vite
sur dans une nouvelle vidéo tient tout
le monde pissas
[Musique]
m